[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya con nosotros en el
estudio Marta llegamos finalmente al
viernes y empezamos con un tema de total
actualidad del día de hoy porque se
acaba de entregar Hace unas horas atrás
el premio Nobel de paz activistas Rusia
y Ucrania Marta pero este premio siempre
beneficia a los galardonados usted nos
dice porque así Raúl buenos días abrimos
con un artículo del San Diego y unión
tribune que titula el Nobel de la paz no
siempre ayuda a quienes se lo llevan
esto referido a los últimos galardonados
en la edición pasada de 2021 Y es que
bueno el Nobel de la paz implica que las
organizaciones o aquellos galardonados
sigan trabajando en sus luchas sin
embargo pues estos dos periodistas
Dimitri muratov Ruso y María arresa
filipina Todavía siguen luchando por
hacer sobrevivir sus medios frente a la
restricciones y expresión de sus
gobiernos el año pasado La Academia los
premio por citotextualmente sus
esfuerzos por preservar la libertad de
expresión que es una precondición para
la democracia y una paz duradera sin
embargo un año después Dimitri murat
editor del periódico nos vaya gaseta ha
visto bueno como su trabajo sea
interrumpido por la guerra en Ucrania y
ha sido totalmente reprimido por el
kremlin que impulsó hasta apenas de 15
años de cárcel por presentar noticias
falsas entre comillas o criticar a las
fuerzas armadas por eso Muchos
periodistas se tuvieron que ir de Rusia
y en este medio crearon una versión
europea que es él nos vaya a gaceta
europe por su parte María reza filipina
ha estado siempre perseguida por el
régimen desde su creación en 2012 pero
con el gobierno de Rodrigo duterte fue
el ya el sumo no eduterte dejó el cargo
En junio pero los problemas legales para
esta periodista no acabaron porque dos
días antes de que duterte dejara el
puesto pidió revocar la licencia de
rapel de este medio que fue muy crítico
sobre todo con la política o sea con la
persecución a la política del
narcotráfico que impulsó el presidente
filipino entonces y por la que murieron
miles de personas entre ellos miles de
trabajadores y vendedores ambulantes
Marta y nosotros continuamos Porque ya
que concluyeron estos Nobel 2022 ya
sabemos Cuánto dinero van a recibir
estos galardonados nos lo cuenta el
periódico español abc hacía Raúl el ABC
titula Cuánto dinero se lleva el premio
Nobel de paz esos premios que bueno se
celebran desde el año 1901 por voluntad
del ingeniero sueco Alfred Nobel él dijo
bueno que una de sus voluntades era
hacer estos premios Son seis premios y
ya sabemos un poco la cantidad que han
percibido este año la cantidad ha ido
variando largo de los años a principios
del siglo XX eran aproximadamente 14.000
euros en los últimos años ascendió hasta
830.000 euros y 2021 y 2022 es la cifra
más alta porque los galardonados reciben
un total aproximadamente de un millón de
euros y cambiamos radicalmente de tema
ahora Marta Porque el medio
estadounidense de intercept señala que
algunos de los gigantes tecnológicos
pudieron haber estado involucrados
indirectamente a financiar la sentencia
que derogó el derecho al aborto en ese
país sí Raúl hablamos de este análisis
que es un poco controvertido y quizás no
es tan literal como lo muestra este
titular como Amazon Google y Facebook
ayudaron a financiar la campaña para
anular Row estos gigantes tecnológicos
financiaron años atrás a un grupo que se
llama foro de mujeres independientes que
trabajó para crear este foro una súper
mayoría en la bueno en la Corte Suprema
claro tenemos que matizar que y las
grandes tecnológicas ni este foro de
mujeres independientes tienen la
capacidad para nombrar a ningún juez en
la Corte Suprema sin embargo este foro
ha hecho lobby durante años y sea
posicionado muy bien entre los
conservadores y ha impulsado en estos
foros informales Pues el papel de estos
jueces conservadores a lo largo de los
años no hicieron una campaña abierta
para las nominaciones de Clarence Thomas
de bretkoverman y de más recientemente
Amy Barrett además han promovido pues
otras cuestiones afines a los
conservadores como el negacionismo de la
crisis climática o el alarmismo
antiinmigratorio además bueno destaca
este este informe que las grandes
tecnológicas financiaron en los últimos
años eventos de este foro de mujeres
independientes y bueno que este foro en
esos eventos homenajeó a figuras como
Bueno muy cerca al ala más conservadora
y antiabortista del gobierno de Donald
Trump
Marta hoy terminamos entonces la semana
en el espacio con un artículo de
National geográfica que nos habla de las
estrellas Así es hablamos del Y es que
esta semana desde el 4 al 10 de octubre
es la semana del espacio y explicamos
rápidamente este artículo que se titula
Nova y supernova como muere en las
estrellas Raúl este artículo dice Bueno
Explica cómo los astros con una masa 100
veces mayor al sol explosionan y dejan o
sea nada o sea explotan y no dejan nada
a su paso los cuerpos celestes que
tienen un ciclo vital de mil millones de
años estas estrellas cuando se agotan
esta composición de elementos el
combustibles se expanden y crean una
estrella gigante roja que está formada
por otros elementos como oxígeno carbono
o hierro cuando esos elementos se agotan
crean una estrella enana blanca que se
identifica porque se consume toda la
combustión de hidrógeno posible esta se
comprime hasta generar una explosión que
se expande por todo el universo y
depende entonces de las características
que se formen una supernova o una nueva
Marta como siempre Muchísimas gracias
por toda la información feliz fin de
semana el lunes con más revista de
prensa pasamos a saludar a nuestra
primera invitada del día Marta gracias
gracias